so first of all sorry we got the order
wrong yeah I went before one of the
episodes and explained that the DV did
they send us is a typical Cartoon
Network DVD so like half the episodes
aren't on there they're out of order
who does that carboy words you want then
they do it a lot the hell's your guys's
problem I think it's kind of like the
old Ren and Stimpy image eternal VHS is
where it's like oh who cares if they're
out of order whatever it's like some
point I'm assuming there's gonna be a
story art or it's gonna matter so yeah
uh it's not like to see it in order it's
like they wanted us to see it um
unfortunately it didn't matter that much
so far away I feel like I could still
watch these that's not like about your
time yeah we man if nobody pointed that
out why probably like 40 episodes now
all the sudden we do it what the hell
yeah um so yeah so we're just gonna
watch them on Amazon now we're not going
buy the DVDs no so this is this is
technically number three I think yeah a
cheeseburger backpack cheeseburger
backpack
cheeseburger backpack we got so much to
say about this one
cheeseburger backpack cheeseburger
backpack uh yeah I spell it there they
have I have a medical condition they
have to total sugar we can put this
statue in the some in some sort of other
statue to restore this place back to it
in the Super Mario World Tower level
yeah it remind me a lot of a mining or
what was it that Mario World one where
it's like you're kind of in a cave kind
of is they over my view everything or I
know the star right yeah we're there one
of the kids were hanging out and I felt
like they should be riding Yoshi
somewhere that's all I'm gonna say that
some of the production design layout
design in this one I had a Mario World
field that's this attic crack in it I
actually enjoyed watching it very much
uh uh and he has his cheeseburger
backpack which he knows is really gonna
help and he puts a bunch of stuff in
there and my favorite is putting in the
doll over the first stage it doesn't
that's pretty funny um and they and they
go through and a lot of his ideas help
but not all of them just have this I did
like the raft because he tosses it in
in my car to logic head I thought oh
it'll just stay there like idea my wrong
way it's going that way isn't it gonna
fall yeah I guess I just thought that
they weren't going to do that like I
thought was his car to lodging so you
don't grab you River it stays it doesn't
move you have to paddle into it but nope
it was it so they go and they he leaves
the the statue back though so he tries
to put his doll in there it gets blown
up and the place is pretty much
destroyed but they're like whatevs you
know you took two out of four is the
best beach in yourself three-hour paddle
back who was white bagel oh I didn't
love the logic of the the crystal shrimp
when he tosses yes well take the name
crystal shrimp I love that even which is
look out it's crystal shrimp I'm like
what a great cop that was one of the
many alternate names for my garage band
recognize the crystal shrimp ah though
we ended up going with white noise which
was the most appropriate um no it cuz i
sat there laughs because like how did
you know that would work
Perl acid and see what this is like well
if I were a crystal shrimp that's what I
would want to do and I set then I'm like
I was like if I were a shrimp I'd want
to cheese bagel as well like I'm a
grown-ass adult I want a cheese bagel
right now yellow all right well done I
want a cheeseburger myself this show is
not good and having you eat healthy
because there's a lot of tasty looking
food and the whole thing kind of looks
like Candyland yeah some things um but
but you brought up and I can't nose to
to the animation looked a little
different I think she was weird I don't
know different animation companies like
per episode and stuff like that like
most shows do but uh and this Steven
particularly looked very odd and I know
it's one of those things but I love
again it's like Finn at Adventure Time
they make them with God sometimes it
like he looked really odd like
unappealing to look at I just I present
to you about three minutes in and I'm
like does this animation seem off or
difference about you're like yeah so we
both noticed it and I don't know if it's
a different company or if they were just
trying something new but I don't know if
I like this one as much the style
whatever they're good cuz it just I know
it was weird
yeah I mean it's um but kind of thinking
I guess because it's like you know it's
still you know compose it looks nice and
the farm shots and the colors are so
nice and stuff but yeah something about
particularly on Steven looked a little
weird
um but outside of the holiday what do
you say about that
I like the mailman in the opening I want
the inevitable on what they're gonna
have to make because amethyst completely
smashed that egg in the fridge uh I you
know the little things that just make
Steven sort of like so innocent and cute
young and stuff like you know he says
yeah I need to see you know you know
what saved my world giving me the
signature my boss gets really mad at me
if I don't get the signature he it's
like that's awful I bet he gets called
away that's something else I'm like you
didn't really need that line that's a
totally pointless live but it's like
it's a very sweet lie it's a very nice
thing to say
you know I mean this mailman who you
know you have no idea if you believe
this kid or not
how many people actually know that
Steven universe hey I do like again that
just like the Care Bears like pearls
automatic plans somehow involves
violence it always kind of comes down to
violence for these cute little
characters you know particularly pearls
like you go here you go here I'm gonna
attack from up high and I'm like what's
fuckin Krystal shrimp do to you but I
don't know where they're going with this
somebody was like no they have to
collect the gems for reason but like
just not knowing where it's going like
at the moment I'm like ah these chicks
are brutal like anything then counters I
kill it I like the the hologram
projecting showing where they're gonna
go and stuff but that was a pretty cool
idea and sort of them what can wait
chess pieces like a little details like
family you could just show them like a
hologram version of themselves but makes
them look a little chess pieces like you
know hey this you know look we're
creating uh so I like that um I do like
the layout of data now I think about
you're talking about the Mario world
you're talking about like sir like the
Cathedral well of those like the kind of
like the towers where the Koopa Kids
were hanging yeah okay that we get up I
like that even are one of those designs
of the clouds in the background head
that Mario world feel to it
a little cartoon clouds yeah come on
played Mario or Lea that's such a good
game um dammit we have to watch Steven
universe and now you've made promises of
Mario World
I didn't make proposition I want to play
I do still have the Super Nintendo
summer I have no idea but why would you
tell me this because I have no idea I'll
still hook up to the TV he'll think the
wires are probably totally well you know
we're gonna do now we're gonna fucking
find out um we'll see you in the next
episode sorry folks
he told me that there's a Super Nintendo
lying around here blame him
we might have a really good review of
Super Mario Plus sweet
Super Mario universe I should be in a
game should we go that did better than
that